russia has halted gas supplies to poland
and bulgaria it says the two nations
refuse to pay in rubles eu calls it
blackmail and says it has contingency
plans but can europeans survive without
russian gas this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm laura kyle
the crisis between russia and europe
sparked by the war in ukraine has taken
yet another turn this time moscow has
delivered on its promise to halt gas
supplies to bulgaria and poland for not
paying in rubles russia's currency
though the action had been feared by
some in the european union many had
already predicted it bulgaria says it's
made alternative arrangements and poland
insists its energy supplies are secure
at the start of the conflict the u.s
agreed to provide liquefied natural gas
to the eu in the coming years and member
states are working to find alternative
long-term supplies as well european
leaders are calling russia's move
blackmail and are promising to respond
gazprom's announcement that it is
unilaterally stopping gas deliveries to
certain eu member states is another
provocation from the kremlin
but it comes as no surprise
that the kremlin uses fossil fuels to
try to blackmail us
this is something the european
commission has been preparing for in
close coordination and solidarity with
member states and international partners
our response will be immediate
united and coordinated
well the european council president
shall michelle icko echoed a similar
message on twitter saying gazprom's
decision to cut gas supplies to some eu
member states is another aggressive
unilateral move by russia we will remain
united and support each other while
phasing out russian energy imports
well some in the eu see this as an
opportunity to revisit the issue of
renewable energy sources to achieve that
the eu would need to raise the share of
its green energy to 40 percent of total
consumption by 2030. another step would
be to collectively reduce net greenhouse
gas emissions by 55 from 1990 levels by
2030 and the eu may have to divert its
attention to alternatives like liquefied
natural gas and even more
controversially resort to reactivating
its coal-powered plants
well ending its reliance on russian gas
will not be an easy task for europe the
eu received more than 40 percent of its
supplies from russia before the war
about a third of that went through
ukraine germany is the biggest single
consumer accounting for 55 of its total
imports but it's now promised to phase
out russian imports bulgaria which has
just been cut off by gazprom receives
more than 70 of its natural gas from
russia while poland gets more than 45
percent
well let's bring in our guests now and
joining us from berlin andreas goldfell
professor at the willie brandt school of
public policy in moscow chris wiefer
chief executive officer at the
consultancy macro advisory and in oslo
ulevalby a commodities analyst at seb
financial services group a very warm
welcome to all of you let's start this
discussion by addressing this issue of
actually paying for russia's gas in
rubles why poland and bulgaria have
refused to do it who else might be doing
it and and why russia wants it in the
first place first oulay why have poland
and bulgaria defied russia's demands
what we're seeing is that poland and
bulgaria are both now
going away from russia as a supply
source of natural gas
and just also just going back four weeks
we saw that the
pollen actually promoted the most
radical plan in eu to diversify its
energy imports so basically what they
stated that was there will be no
no russian call in two months time there
will be no russian oil by the end of
2022 and there will be no extension on
their russian natural gas contracts
which is about expired at the end of
2022 so this has sort of been um
this has been important politics in
poland and also bulgaria of course
and
so now we're seeing that this is
opportunity to go away from russia's
supply source and now we also see that
they have alternatives and bulgaria does
as well because it gets its vast
majority of natural gas from russia
exactly exactly that's a good point but
bulgaria can get their gas from
azerbaijan now we see that they are
signing more long-term contracts with
the azerbaijani gas okay
chris let's look at russia and why it's
insisting on these rubles payments in
the first place i mean i understand that
gazprom already has to sell 80 of its
foreign currency earnings for russian
currency anyway
so why is it insisting on
more of these ruble payments
yes and actually just very quickly uh on
what previous speakers said uh the
reason why russia has targeted poland in
bulgaria is exactly as he said these are
the two countries that have been more
proactive
in uh looking for alternative sources
and making specific arrangements for uh
alternative uh
gas supplies and both countries where in
any case going to drop russia and gas
supplies at the end of the year so it
allows russia therefore
opportunistically to make a point to to
basically say to the other countries uh
we can do the same to to you even though
the volumes would be a lot more
significant and the impact would be a
lot bigger because other countries like
germany italy etc have not made these
arrangements because they're not
possible but as to why now it's it look
it's partly
this is something that president putin
and the government have talked about for
a very long time more than 10 years uh
the fact that they've wanted to break
dependency on the dollar as the main
currency for russia's external trade
they've wanted more bilateral currency
deals there are some in place with china
in rubles and chinese one
so this is something that they've been
in any case promoting for a long time
and now this is an opportunity to
advance that but actually the reason why
they're doing it specifically now is
related to sanctions because
the mechanism that they've proposed
are that they've put in place which
requires for example a customer in
europe to pay still be able to pay
dollars or euros but now into a bank
account in gazprom bank and gas from
bank then converts to rubles and
transmits the rubles to to gas from so
the customer can still pay in dollars or
euros but in this mechanism and the eu
commissioner saying that this mechanism
is sanctions violating because it
involves a russian central bank and
hence they're they're opposed to it so
russia is pushing it now
in order to make these sanctions against
the central bank uh
well shall we say very uncomfortable for
europe and raising the stakes about
future sanctions absolutely well it
certainly has succeeded there in raising
the stakes andreas given the number of
countries that are still receiving
russian gas at this time should we
can we assume that some or even many are
actually paying in rubles well there are
reports that this is already happening
or at least companies and at least three
or four european countries are
now paying in rural precisely along the
lines of what chris has just outlined uh
we don't precisely know whom we have
fair certainty on on hungary uh probably
austria i wouldn't rule out that some
german companies are trying the same
thing given the rather difficult
situation these days and i'm not ruling
out this is this is gonna go uh
that number is gonna go even higher up
uh i guess the key issue here really is
you know uh
where is the pressure what what kind of
pressure is higher the political
pressure from the european side to stay
in line or essentially the the pressure
to keep up the gas supply is flowing and
and that's where companies find
themselves between a rock and a hard
place at the moment
absolutely the sanctions it has said are
only as strong as their weakest link is
this russian move to insist on payment
in rubles thereby violating eu sanctions
according to the eu commission president
is that working i think it's you know
back to that what the second speaker
mentioned here and i we saw that he used
von delay and i mentioned that the
pain in rubles will be viewed as a
sanction violation right
and then and i think that's what's
driving the price you know that's what's
driving the price because whole and
and as alone is it's not a major there's
no major issue for for poll at all so
it's more like a psychological thing and
more like a psychological effect on the
market and this is the power play putin
and gascon has been has been driving
the last couple of uh six plus months um
going back and
i think
it works in some way because now you see
that
the countries which is really reliant on
on the russian natural gas they will now
pay in rubles and be the consequence and
i think now the market now realizes the
seriousness of the cons of
the actions and we see that even though
the price didn't like of course it
jumped back up quite a bit but not
not like a really huge extent what we
saw happening was that the
forward curve the prices further out on
the curve going forward they went up so
i think the market's now realizing
that this will be no easy and quick fix
right so going forward we will have
higher prices for longer and i think
that's exactly also what putin wants and
also one quick comment as well i think
you know putin has been delivering on
his long-term obligation his long-term
contracts all the time you know he's
been playing with the spot volumes as
much so
and he only his goal is to make sure
that his large consumers of natural gas
his customers in europe are now going
into new long-term contracts which is
about to expire you know natural gas is
like a marriage you know it's like it's
like a it's like a 20
20 30
uh
30-year handshake you know and this is
exactly what he wants
so i think it sort of works yes
okay would you agree with that chris if
you can uh sort of perhaps look into
putin's mind simply because you're there
in moscow
do you think that this is his outlook
yeah look i i think first of all as we
said russia
views these relationships over the very
long term and it is actually important
to note that
the the
russian government uh always made a
point that it will always honor
contracts so in this situation it's
actually make it's about making like
life difficult for the european
customers rather than perhaps risking
the contracts because
you know german or other european
customers can still pay in dollars or
euros as per the contract but they now
have to pay into gazprom bank
rather than to gazprom and hence the
conversion to rubles from there so
essentially what russia is saying is
that technically the contract is not
disrupted it is only the payment
mechanism that has changed and therefore
they're again throwing the onus on the
on europe and the european customers to
uh as well as eu commission president
said to break sanctions but but russia
itself is saying we're actually not
doing much to the contracts only
changing where you pay not how you pay
are the terms of the contract itself so
in that sense of course russia is in a
strong position
although you really have to
always reflect on the fact that
russia and europe are in a mutually
difficult position europe needs to guess
but russia needs the money
so in that sense you're not going to get
a situation where russia will just
arbitrarily turn the gas off because it
needs the financial lifeline in order to
sustain the economy and provide
employment subsidies social subsidies
etc uh the situation in russia will be
very difficult
difficult and very different tomorrow if
those gas flows were cut off and the
money stream was disrupted so in that
sense there's a lot of bluffing there's
a game of brinksmanship there's a game
of chicken it'll play out over the
summer when frankly the the energy
market is kind of uh
kind of like it requires maybe less
volumes it's a good time to play it uh
and the hope here in moscow is as far as
i can hear is that they hope that all of
this will be resolved and dusted and
finalized before we get to the autumn
delivery season hmm that'll be
interesting andreas do you think russia
might lose this bluff we've got the eu
standing resolute saying its response is
immediate and coordinated we know that
they're coming up with this re-power eu
plan is it going to be enough to wean
themselves off russia's fossil fuels
well i think there's two things one i
think the jury is out whether the front
is standing and holding i mean we need a
european
well a coordinated european
answer to the russian demand and at the
moment a couple of countries are there
their companies are breaking out of that
i think what's really really needed is
is uh is a coordinated response and
people working on this whether it holds
the jury's out but but then obviously
the the longer term question is you know
does europe need
russia's gas going forward and you know
uh two months ago or three months ago i
would have said yes well it is
a reality to live with for a couple of
years or a decade now i'm not so sure
anymore because if you look at just
essentially if you if you connect the
dots the germans are ramping up uh
solar tenders to up to 20 gigawatts by
28. um the dutch are
um are doubling their uh their offshore
wind uh capacity until 2030. we've we've
seen similar moves in italy um
across europe uh companies and and
governments are pouring billions into
climate measures and the energy
transition so i guess what this really
means is uh that on on the demand side
we'll see a fuel switch to the extent
that you can replace molecules in uh in
heating uh and and uh in power
generation and that will destroy demand
for gas and that's a reality russia has
to live with going forward and and all
of that is massively accelerated at this
point
so chris if this does backfire
does russia risk becoming an economic
prior as the uk has said it will do and
does it risk putin's very
future well i think when you say
backfire i i think it is now absolutely
inevitable that europe will buy less
russian energy regardless of what
happens next but regardless of
you know what happens to sanctions etc i
think that's now that game is now to
change uh for good uh but in russia is
it's also a case that russia does not
want to be as dependent on europe as a
its major energy customer uh either and
for example since 2014 uh when when
europe started talking about russia
russian energy
risk in moscow the conversation was
about also russia's exposure to european
europe as an energy customer and since
2014 we've seen major projects being
built uh focusing on china in gas and
oil and lng and and the discussion in
moscow right now is acknowledging that
europe has begun to become steadily and
less important
customer but asia china india particular
are all going to become bigger customers
and compensate so the view in moscow is
that this is about rebalancing it is
inevitable that europe will go down as a
customer but they will be compensated
with new customer growth elsewhere
that's the way they're looking at it
right now uh so therefore the view in
moscow is that it's rebalancing and it's
not going to destroy the economy but
clearly it all depends on on scale and
time and the urgency that this uh that
this will all be uh rolled out over um
what are your thoughts on that
yeah no i know that's a really really
interesting point this is something we
work a lot with with our clients as well
trying to understand the re-routing
capabilities
for uh for
natural gas and what we have seen and
just speaking of how it looks like
looking right now is that we see that we
have around
the export capacity going going
going east into china that's around uh
at max 400 hours per year if you compare
that what's going flowing into the
western european market through the
yamal pipeline the northern one pipeline
and also the major
brotherhood pipeline going through
ukraine that's around 1700. so then you
get the idea of the scale of the
european market and that's a really
really interesting
interesting topic that i i totally agree
russians are really really reliant
enough
at us as well but we also see that there
is um expansion plans for the for
example the power of siberia a huge part
of angola in china which is but that's
scheduled to come online uh at around
20 20 30. it's you know it's
more than one eight years so so um
i think it's important to have have that
and have that in mind
just ask them now europe is just too
large customer
yeah all plans do seem to be hinging on
2030. it's going to be interesting to
see how many of them can be and will be
sped up to deal with this particular
crisis andreas if there was ever a time
to invest in renewable energy it's now
or rather it was before now with the
climate crisis ever present and now
these supplies of fossil fuels uncertain
are we seeing enough effort down that
road
well i mean
i think it's the best time ever to do
that particularly in europe and in
places where government support is is
being ramped up and where you not only
have an economic case but also a strong
security case now a national security
case
as some politicians would make
would make it but um uh i think the the
one bottleneck here obviously is global
supply chains and what we have seen is
is some of the material uh and and some
of the parts that are needed
to really ramp up uh a renewable
capacity are not available because of
various bottlenecks across the globe and
because of um you know the knock-on
effects of a covert crisis still so you
know
on the one side we have aspiration and
good business cases and and i guess
great opportunity particularly in europe
and in the ocd world but on the other
hand we face serious constraints when it
comes to delivering and and i guess
that's that's something that
that many european markets have to
grapple with going forward
and
you know there's talk of filling in a
short-term gap uh as you shift from gas
with coal
and if we're sticking with the climate
crisis for a moment i mean this is going
to ensure a massive rise in greenhouse
gas emissions
yeah definitely this is this is really
really bad for the environment you know
if you go back a few years time
at least last four to five years you
know esg and environment has been
everything on the agenda it's been all
about the environment all the time and
now we see that suddenly it's all about
the security of supply you know
cost whatever it costs you can you can
burn whatever you find you can burn all
the car tires you can burn whatever you
you have in mind it doesn't matter now
it's all about surviving and then makes
making sure that the industry keeps on
delivering uh so so environment and
price is set aside and then you have the
secure supply which is uh top of the
agenda now
and also back to the question uh just to
you mentioned here is that you know if
you look into renewables if we look back
in his historical you see that the
historical average power price in the
european
union has been around 40 euros per
megawatt hours you know and coming out
of kovit and coming out of this war
crisis we see that we are likely to have
a
the average power price with somewhere
between 70 and 100 euros per million
dollars you know this is huge this is
also because at the time of corvid and
at the time of the war we have been
having increased uh the prices for uh
for
carbon cost
so
definitely going back to the question
regarding renewables this is really big
business for renewables and you will
have uh they'll basically be a
massive cash machine and building
renewables and generating power from the
room at these levels just just uh
slightly off topic but interesting
nonetheless chris is there much drive
for renewables in russia
you know it's been a really interesting
debate uh in in russia up to up to now
uh where on the one side you've got the
very powerful kind of hydrocarbon sector
the big oil companies big gas companies
essentially have been saying that
russia should take its time about moving
into renewables that the world will
still need oil and gas you know right
into the middle of the next decade and
russia needs to invest more in oil and
gas to supply and then you've had the
emerging of course force talking about
renewables and the inevitability of
fine reduction so it's been a big debate
in a big battle in in russia
clearly you know one of the the
consequences of this conflict will be an
acceleration in investment renewables
that's absolutely clear we have simply
no idea as to how that will play out in
russia uh
a a as a theme
also uh when the crisis ends uh but for
sure it's something that will again have
to be addressed but before crisis it was
a debate but without any clear
conclusion
andreas campaigners they say one of the
problems with renewables is the cost and
that the government must protect the
very poorest from energy price rises i
mean we're going to see energy price
rises anyway with the russia uh invasion
of ukraine and then and
stopping the flow of gas to european
nations but what can governments do to
protect consumers
well i think there's a couple of things
i mean i think the first thing that
that government should be doing is
incentivize savings and they are not
doing enough at the moment governments
across europe um rely on the price to
deliver savings but savings
will not necessarily always come through
simply because the price is high to some
extent because the signal isn't direct
but indirect sometimes there is
no necessity on the demand side
responding uh
to price hikes and so the government can
do a lot of things and um i would start
with industry just to make sure we don't
have end up in a situation where
rationing is is important and becomes at
the name of the game and i think
european governments can do a lot more
here to show to shield consumers but on
the other hand
you know we have
we have a whole policy toolbox to do
that and we have tested it during covet
just think about
checks that were sent to poorer families
or lower income households
to buffer some of the consequences you
can do this in a very targeted way you
can
you can lower taxes on electricity for
instance and and that is a direct
subsidy if you will uh to lower income
households simply because they spend an
overproportional share of their income
on energy services and so so there's
lots of things that you can do what you
should not be doing is is
is essentially just you know
regulate the price across the board and
just make sure the the
price hikes are no longer felt by
consumers because that in the end
you neither trigger
savings nor shield the right people okay
such an interesting discussion today
thank you very much to all of you for
joining us andreas goldfell chris wifer
and ule valby
and thank you too for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website there's al
jazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
laura kyle and the entire team here in
doha it's bye for now
[Music]